I was watching I was watching The
Bachelor on television yeah we all know
that show The Bachelor I was watching it
for a while then I hit the info button
and it said week after week a large
group of women demean themselves by
watching this television show Gotham I
was watching the show Gotham and then I
hit the info button and it said you'll
enjoy this show if you're one complaint
about Batman was too much Batman 19 Kids
and Counting yeah watching 19 Kids and
Counting I didn't do anything yet people
19 Kids and Counting and then I hit the
info button and it said a show that
couldn't get creepier just
c-span
I was watching c-span I don't know why
but I was and then I hit the info button
and it said still the best way to get
mental patients to the real of watching
The Real Housewives of Melbourne yes the
Real Housewives of Melbourne and then I
hit the info button and it said Shh
don't tell anyone but this show is
actually just slightly blurry reruns of
route I was watching NCIS New Orleans I
hit the info button and it said come on
down to New Orleans for some murder and
sexual assault agents I was watching the
little couple
the little couple yeah and then I hit
the info button and it said finally it's
okay to stare
Finding Bigfoot Finding Bigfoot hit hit
the button and it said by focusing on
tracking down a non-existent creature
men avoid complicated domestic
situations with their wives and children
big blue finally diners drive-ins and
dives
yeah then I hit the button it said just
off camera gunman forced innocent chefs
to cook for the evil villain lychee Oh
[Applause]
we can
here wasn't that a great clip subscribe
to my youtube channel for an endless
supply of me
[Laughter]